[موسيقى] تم
إشعال النار في بعض الملابس، وتم تصميم بعضها الآخر
للانهيار، وكان
أحد المدرج مليئًا بالكلاب الآلية،
ولم يكن هناك شيء خطير جدًا أو شنيع في
موسم الموضة هذا، حيث طاردت العلامات التجارية
لحظات مسرحية صغيرة مخصصة
لوسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
رأينا أنماطًا وألوانًا  تظهر أمام
أعيننا بفضل تقنية الأشعة فوق البنفسجية التي
تتصفحها عارضات الأزياء وحتى مجموعات
عروض الأزياء التي تدمر نفسها ذاتيًا، والتي تتميز بلحظات مذهلة منذ فترة طويلة،
ولكن الكثير مما
رأيناه مؤخرًا لحظات من
العفوية الهادفة يبدو منسقًا
للشاشة الأصغر في يناير الدنماركي.
أحدث قسم العلامات التجارية موجات من خلال
عنصر حي صدم الجماهير،
وقد
تمت مشاهدة مقطع فيديو للكشف عن العلامة التجارية أكثر من 5 ملايين مرة،
ولا يقتصر الأمر على العلامات التجارية الناشئة التي
تقفز على هذا الاتجاه،
فقد تكون الخيول على منصة ستيلا مكارتني مدربة
تدريباً عالياً  لكن
مظهرهم الجامح هو ما لفت
انتباه الجمهور لأن كل عناصرهم الحية المبتكرة
ليست اتجاهًا جديدًا تمامًا، وقد
تصدرت العلامة التجارية الفرنسية كابوني عناوين الأخبار عندما
خرج المظهر الختامي لبيلا حديد من علبة رذاذ في
سبتمبر الماضي، لكن ألكساندر ماكوين
فعل شيئًا مشابهًا بشكل لافت للنظر مرة أخرى في  في عام
1998، عندما تم طلاء فستان أبيض نقي
كان يرتديه شالوم هارلو بواسطة
روبوتين،
كان كلاهما من الأمثلة التي يمكن أن تكون فيها الأعمال المثيرة الإعلامية
أيضًا بداية محادثة
تتساءل عن طريقة تصميم الملابس
[موسيقى]
إذا كنت من محبي الموضة، فلا تخف من
العلامات القديمة لويس فويتون شانيل
وابتعد ميو ميو عن اللحظات واسعة الانتشار
متمسكًا بتصميم مرتفع
لا يتنافس مع الملابس أو
ينهار في النهاية
[موسيقى]